this is uh Christy Yamaguchi main said
the Taco Bell drive through at 1am will
have a 200 000 Mercedes S65 waiting
right behind a 96 Cavalier that's never
had the oil changed followed by a moped
ridden by three people all craving the
same thing to live Moss truly the last
great Melting Pot of class in this
country that's it but that that it's
this is this is literally true because
uh we got a local Taco Bell out here and
I haven't I didn't have Taco Bell in
like a decade and then me and my
girlfriend were driving oh no no the
first time was we I was we were Sheamus
and we drove past at Taco Bell and
Sheamus was like he asked us if we
wanted to live moss and we were like I
mean Taco Bell is really good and so I'm
in a Tesla and we pull up behind like a
like a Honda Civic and there's like a
Toyota and it's exactly the story we
just cheesy gordita crunches man those
are good